this is a pepper panic saga levels 55
walkthrough tutorial
making this for a request we had on our
youtube channel
this is a tough level
because the statues are off to the side
if you've read read our full guide you
know that we what we're trying to do is
we're trying to
free up
whichever colors we have closest to the
statue so that we can get them to
explode
and so we look over in the beginning and
we'll see that yellow
is by both of the statues so we want to
try to focus on yellow if we can
we also need to avoid the cat as much as
possible
and
right now we don't have any real big
yellow matches
so we're going to want to bring
more peppers down by making matches at
the bottom
and then we just want to kind of
strategically want to move
the yellow peppers together like we did
right there
one of the first frustrating things
about this level is that you know you
have this
you have these grown peppers sitting
around but you don't always get to use
them before he gets there
so sometimes you're just going to have
to give up whenever that happens
and so yeah like here we there's just no
way we can get that one to explode so
we'll switch our focus and move up to
the top where he's not at
all right so that's our first explosion
you see that gets the
that gets things started now we want to
try to
completely free those yellow peppers so
that we'll be able to use them so
by working away from him
we're just trying to set that up
so now we have yellow peppers sitting
free next to the statues so if we can
get those to explode we'll be able to
damage the statue
there i'm just trying to you know move
these larger yellow peppers out of his
way
same with this match
and
whenever you have the color that you
need
you can make a five pepper match with
that that's always going to be a good
choice like i made there
so now by exploding this pepper see now
we can actually
cause damage to the statues right away
we're going to completely remove the top
statue and now we have the bottom one
where it only needs one more hit
and even though
even though the purple is
also near the statue
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to get the
orange first we'll keep the purple in
mind but
this orange one will finish things off
so we want to go there if we
can go ahead and knock him out for one
more move as you can see by the stars
over his head he's down for three moves
right now
which is helpful considering we we want
to um
you know get this to explode before he
comes back to give us problems
so we're just looking for orange matches
and moving things around when they're
not there
and we're in a pretty good spot because
he's all the way at the top so we have
quite a few moves till he gets down here
so you see i'm just moving things
trying to get these orange peppers
together
and it's a little bit tedious but
this is going to end things right here
we're going to make a big
match here that's going to shock wave
and grow this and it's also going to
start a chain reaction with our stage 5
so that's going to that's going to do it
so you see that
just like our full guide says
you want to you want to just focus on
whichever colors are closest to the
statues and get those to explode
there's no real
need to
free all those that are all peppers from
the ice and sometimes that can even make
things a little bit more difficult so
you want to sometimes preserve those
so that you know your pepper will sit
right where you want them to
most of the time
you're gonna you know you're gonna be
battling with the cat and so you see how
we just worked away from him and tried
to keep things
moving
when he wasn't around
i hope this helps if you have any any
questions comment make another comment
and
we'll try to help you out
definitely be sure to read our full
guide which will be linked from the
video
that goes into more detail about the
strategy and
we'll be making more videos like this
one soon so thanks